ce que je disais tout à l'heure si si on
se fie à l'envi j'ai envie de te dire
que ils l'ont tué bah oui mais on peut
pas on peut pas parce que chaque action
entraîne une réaction s'ils l'ont tué on
peut pas rester comme ça donc on va dire
ils n'ont pas tué on va dire on sait pas
et on verra
mais je sais que vendredi sécurité dans
une colère qui n'est pas dans une colère
ici qui c'est un acte totalement gratuit
il a offert une cigarette et la paix il
a payé le fait d'offrir un cigare et
intérim incompréhensible on pense à
incompréhensible quelqu'un qu'on connaît
que tout le monde connaît qui l'appelle
par son prénom c'est un moment est-ce
que tu as pensé de faire justice tous
les jours j'y pense tous les jours tous
les jours mais c'est exactement ce qu'il
ne faut pas faire et c'est ce que tu
viens de dire sur ce film a été revu par
et c'est ce que ne voulait pas ali bien
sûr et c'est ce qu'il ne faut pas faire
parce que je suis parent moi même j'ai
des enfants et et quelle image on va
donner quelle est cette société où on
pour coup on fait comment c'est d'abord
ça me ramènera pas ali je suis ensuite
derrière lui aussi à des parents lui
aussi a des frères et soeurs qui sont
dans un état catastrophique qu'est ce
qu'on fait qu'est-ce qu'on fait que je
trouve que le message
c'est un discours incroyable charland
logique parce que je te dis ici mais ici
je lis quand il a annoncé sa à vendredi
dont d'été dans une colère incroyable
tout venise et voilà c'est est faite au
site était très très énervé en brie et
là tu as eu le temps tu vois là tu t'es
dit j'y réfléchis je fais pas je vais
pas faire marche aura pas le temps ouais
parce que rld aurait pu l'éviter ce
qu'on aurait pu dormir avec lui à
culpabiliser si j'aurais dû être là
j'aurais dû être plus présent et j'aurai
évidemment maintenant ça ne rendra pas
aller à lille est parti on est croyants
pour nous il est au paradis il peut être
comparé à 10 tant que le reste qu'est ce
qu'on va faire faire pleurer d'autres
familles est ce qu'il ya des proches à
toi des potes d'aider la famille
quittelier dit on dit aussi on est 100 %
des gens te disent quoi c'est pas 90%
c'est 100 % des gens ont peut pas
laisser ça comme ça il faut faire
quelque chose il faut leur faire du mal
il faut non mais ça va pas ou quoi on
est où là haut niveau n'est pas dans
cette société on est on est des humains
on réfléchit avec le cerveau pas avec le
coeur avec mon coeur je les découpe je
les mange avec le cerveau ou jean on
sait par exemple que je veux donner à
mes enfants il n'a pas pensé à la suite
il n'a pas pensé chaque action entraîne
une réaction ils ont fait je veux pas
dire une bêtise parce que c'est plus
qu'une bêtise mais mais lui il doit être
encore plus à genoux que nous là quand
il apprend qu alli est décédé bien sûr
pas en espèces et sa famille sont
comment tu aurais envie de les
rencontrer toi ses agresseurs a envie
non on est enfin très tôt les agresseurs
oui on va dire que je n'entends pas et
sa famille j'ai envie de leur dire que
on leur veut pas du mal et qu'on n'est
pas responsable de ce qui leur arrive
parce qu'ils sont dépités aussi les
familles bien évidemment évidemment
c'est évidemment ils sont qu'ils soient
pas là ils sont dans un état dans une
fratrie il n'y a pas tout tous les
frères sont pas les mêmes en a qui font
des conneries tout ne peut pas subir et
puis ça suffit d'entendre que les gens
ils ont ils ont des parents qui les
aiment pas ou qui les éduquent pas ou
que ces fonds c'est faux on est tous
responsables de nos actions il est
responsable de ses actions passées par
an par son frère pas sa soeur